a safe vaccine that works cannot come
fast enough for businesses and workers
especially those in locations slowing
down the reopening process congressional
correspondent Chad program looks at the
economic concerns and what Congress may
or may not do about it
stark words on Capitol Hill about the
future of the US economy this reversal
of economic fortune has caused a level
of pain that's hard to capture in words
as lives are upended amid great
uncertainty about the future dire
predictions from lawmakers I think we're
gonna see without intervention a wave of
foreclosures and defaults all of the job
gains of the past decade have been wiped
out but Congress takes a two-week break
on Thursday without approving another
coronavirus bill we just can't wait for
our Republican colleagues to wake up to
the reality in this country people are
losing their homes people are not being
fed people are losing their jobs Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell won't
commit to another coronavirus bill the
only thing McConnell's pushing liability
protections to prevent people from suing
if they get sick at work or school these
are the kinds of smart solutions
Washington must continue discussing as
we evaluate what further steps may be
necessary today's the deadline for small
businesses to apply for loans under the
Paycheck protection program Treasury
secretary Steve minuchin told a House
hearing there was bipartisan support for
repurposing the funds remaining 135
billion dollars but that requires
congressional action and there's no
consensus about extending unemployment
benefits set to expire in about a month
an economic reopening is uneven you can
roll the dice again at casinos in
Maryland but the neon lights on Broadway
are dark until at least January and
questions remain about the viability of
pro sports I never said we can't play a
certain sport
I am completely unqualified to tell you
whether you can play a sport or not
experts say Trust is the key to
reopening the path forward for the
economy remains extraordinarily
uncertain and will depend in large part
on our success in containing the virus a
full recovery is unlikely to occur until
people are confident that it's safe to
engage in a broad range of activities
the virus wiped out tax season in April
the new deadline is July 15th the IRS is
sticking to that but refunds may be
delayed by months right Chadd program
live on the hill Chad thanks